all right Gabrielle hi Gabrielle where
are you from originally uh Central
Texas what what city is that uh so ebra
County Hood County area um Steve Mill is
like the big capital of it and there's
not that many people there um but I grew
up in a really much smaller town that
was like well if you had to go in the
city like you're there all day and you
go home um but I grew up on a farm uh
Ranch I guess more to say um we had tons
of cattle animals um and grew up with my
both parents and my
sister how would you describe your
childhood a tornado toric um really it's
more of an emotion I I think of like my
little self I mean it's obviously still
in me um but
very I knew I was going to be emotional
I didn't think it would be this soon um
just very scared as a kid
um really trying to do my best every day
and that's my motto still um but having
to be put through a lot that child um
shouldn't have to see or take care of my
mom she was um sick from my from my time
of birth I would say that maybe me
coming into the world um caused her to
be a little bit um more unwell than she
already was are you an only child no
with well my sister we actually we have
separate Parents separate dads um but we
were raised the same together um she was
more my mom than my mom was so we were
both caretakers of her she's four years
older than me um and
then when my mom ended up passing away
um it even you know I bonded even closer
with my sister because she became the
full parental figure and my dad um left
and you
know trauma is for sure like the root
cause of everything wrong with my family
line all of it Grandparents
great-grandparents you hear these
horrible stories at least I was as a kid
like my mom we were like her only
friends she was bedridden from the you
know from when I was a little kid what
were her
issues oh physically she had like a
paralyzed stomach we don't really know
what the true problem was she could not
digest food she had all of her colon
removed she didn't have a bowel movement
for like 2 years like should have killed
her wrapped her around her heart gave
her a heart attack that's how they found
out like oh something's really wrong um
she was diabetic had heart failure um
mental illness I think it was hand inand
with the physical and the mental um
bipolar she wasn't ever diagnosed though
by like a like a psychiatrist or um
someone who can it was like our general
doctor in the middle of nowhere um and
he would just you know oh I think you
have this here's medication for this oh
it's not working let's give you this
pill so she literally had a tackle box
like four layers of pills that she would
take every single day and it was like
you know morning you would take the top
layer and go down um I think that she
had multiple personalities or did I
think that was the the main problem um
and maybe bipolar to Incorporated with
it maybe borderline personality um her
her behavior would
change vastly um I would say it was the
worst in my most pivotal time 3 to seven
those years um she she was scared so of
course that you know brings fear to the
child um she scared of everything she
was very uh like Southern Baptist you
know the end of the world is coming so
let's meal prep let's build this house
and have a chapel in the middle of the
house it was like a cement room had pews
had a little uh altar thing for the
pastor which would be her I guess um and
that was like our doomsday prep so she
had like canned foods and like stuff
that you can mix with water um clickable
flashlights that are you know handheld
just in case like the end of the world
happens so there's a religious element
to this as well I think I think most of
it the fear about the world ending and
how people are so evil was it was always
demonic right it was always oh it's not
cuz their parents messed them up it was
CU Satan is um in them and so she
started doing that and then she was a
hoarder as well so she from a child
didn't have a lot of anything she grew
very poor um abused by her family as
well and so she took that and was like
okay well I need everything and whatever
I can't have I'm going to give to you so
what do you want clothes do you want um
all the sweet stuff in the world all the
candies all the cakes and I didn't
realize as a child like we were
struggling for money um because she
would just it was whatever I wanted here
you go um but it wasn't ever the
emotional sense it was like you want
Little dubby here you go do you want a
new pair of jeans here you go um and
it's so sad to think like the financial
ruin she put my my dad in um and I think
that if she would have gone to true true
help and not just like the general
doctor that she was going to um it would
have changed her trajectory of life I
don't think she would have had um all
the health conditions I think they are
all rooted from the deep Trauma from her
past as
well so this this lasted until when
uh she passed away when I was 15 I
always say 14 but it was she was 15 I
was 15 um she had her final heart attack
um I
me no
child should ever have to find their
parent dead um I had gone to school and
I have always been very intuitive like
known that things I don't know if I'm
going to have a good day or a bad day or
walking to school is 2 14 and it was
just like rainy and it was foggy and I
was like oh today's not going to be a
good day and I really struggled with
telling my mom I loved her I did um like
I lived to keep her alive that was
really my um my goal and I texted her in
the middle of the day and I was like I
love you like I hope all is okay and I
didn't hear her back I was like oh maybe
she's sleeping cuz she also didn't sleep
like I know you hear like stories of
drug like staying up for 6 days at a
time and it's like she didn't sleep for
months at a time I don't know if it was
psychosis if it was the medicine she was
taking um but I was like oh God I hope
she's sleeping because she's always
nicer when she
slept um and so come home and she was in
bed and I was like oh okay well I guess
I'll go eat with my dad after school and
we came home and um she was just in the
bathroom on the
floor and the first thing I thought of
wasn't let me call like help or 911 it
was I get to live for myself and I felt
so selfish and so upset with myself that
that was the immediate reaction it
wasn't oh my God it was oh I get to be
myself because I became very good at
lying as a kid uh when you have a parent
who is emotionally unwell and unstable
and you know physically abusive you
learn how to be the perfect child and my
dad had a real big problem with the way
I behaved after she died because I
became this kind of rambunctious teen
who for the first time doesn't have to
take care of anybody and can just be a
teenager um and on top of having a brain
injury right before that too I really
had like all this new lease on life and
um I don't think my dad was capable
emotionally um to handle teenage girl um
so I went to live with my my sister
after that um but my mom it's been a
long time since I've been able to like
say anything kind about her she was a
she was beautiful she was great um the
mom that at least I knew I try to look
at the memories and pictures that I've
seen where she was a very kind person um
I think two s when people have children
they all of their unresolved issues
really pile up and it's like oh well I'm
not going to do the things that my
parents did to me but I'm just going to
do it to you differently um and it's
interesting you know all the story she
told me growing up um about how she was
abused and how she
um had these abusive relationships my
life has started to alter that or did
alter that until I you know made a
choice like I'm I'm not going to be like
that I'm going to change it I'm going to
I'm going to be better um cuz I can very
much see that I was going in the exact
same path and I think um the universe
whatever um was like maybe there's
something better for you um I didn't
listen for a long time um but I'm glad
that I finally did yeah and so you you
graduated high school I did graduate
high school um I struggled in high
school a lot um I had to move my senior
year cuz my mom had died and then moved
with my sister
um I always look to my teachers to be
like my mom as a kid um so I was always
like the best in class I always really
you know called them mom I was always
trying to to show up and go beyond cuz I
needed love that I wasn't getting at
home um but I think my my biggest
problem in school was having my brain
injury
um seeing like white like a white board
with like black marker is still very
hard for me to be able to look at um and
I would just so fatigued and tired um
but I got through it and then when I
went when I moved school is my senior
year um that's when things got really
really tough I um started abusing
alcohol um I had a boyfriend at the time
that's kind of how my life is too it's
like I have these boyfriends or did kind
of like my mom and it's like I end up
following suit of them and then really
ruing in my life and then going to the
next one who's very different and it's
like oh well this is a Saving Grace and
it's the same [__] um but abused alcohol
really really bad
um and I think that was like the Turning
Point um in my life when I was 18 I
remember so vividly I've tried
committing suicide twice the first was
when I was 14 the second one when I was
18 um the first one was right after I
had brain surgery um and they were like
well you can't do anything really ever
um we hope that you know you'll be able
to have a good a good life um but we
don't know know really what to expect
you might wake up in 3 days and you know
not be able to talk or walk or in 10
years from now we have no idea um and so
you the brain injury happened at what
age again 14 so it was six months before
my my mom died from like 14 to 18 I
don't know what happened it was hell
that was truly the wor those the were
the worst years of my life um and maybe
three to seven but there's these huge
chunks it's always like four years at a
time I it's a freak accident I was
running with my friends in the park
where I grew up and we were playing tag
and I see my friend he's running I chase
him and I was like oh we fell so I get
to play you know tag him and didn't
think maybe he fell over something so I
fell over cable wires in a parking lot
and then I hit my head on a concrete car
block stop like where the car doesn't go
over
um
and you think when you hit your head
that hard like oh you knock out but I
again like it's these moments of peace
I did not lose Consciousness but I
definitely was not in my body um I
remember I can remember everything as if
like I'm looking down at myself but I'm
in this like very peaceful space and I
don't know if it's I don't necessarily
Believe In Like Heaven um but I don't
know maybe it was just like a peaceful
State I don't know to pull myself out or
if it was my body's uh reaction like in
trauma times where you're dissociating
um but I can see myself like in pain and
just like hurting and I'm really
confused cuz I'm like well I'm fine up
here but like why am I not good down
there so they had to be care flighted um
to Cook's children which is in Fort
Worth and had immediate brain surgery um
had a subdural hematoma which is a blood
clot in my head and it was about about
that big like a softball um on this side
of my head and I actually hit this side
but the force was so bad that it the
blood clots on this side fractured my
skull um my neck obviously had whiplash
tore some ligaments and tendons was in a
neck brace for six weeks um they opened
my head took out the blood clot patched
me up didn't shave my head which I was
very grateful for um and I had a drain
tube for several days in the ICU
afterwards
but went to the surgery anesthesiologist
put me down and I was back in my body
but I don't remember it and then the
moment I woke up from surgery this like
white space that I was in was totally
gone and it was like a vac like the best
way I can describe like a vacuum like
being sucked back in my body to the most
debilitating pain feeling Sensation that
I ever felt hopefully I never feel that
way again um because it was hopeless I
had still had a um a tube down my throat
for ventilation um I could see you know
the blood out of my eye down um through
my head and I wasn't able to I don't
think fully Express like the way that I
was feeling to doctors or my parents
because still my mom was alive so I was
like well I still have to take care of
her I don't get to have the moments to
be sick I don't get to have this time to
really to heal or even address that I'm
not okay so wasn't there for very long
probably a week or so in the hospital
went home and I sitting in my bed I had
like a hospital bed at home where they
could lift me up um my sister had to
shower me during that time cuz I wasn't
able to to move move around um and after
she like left I was like well this is it
like I'm done um so I took like a
handful of like depression meds that I
was taking at the time and like some
Advil and I really thought I was going
to do it and it didn't um and I woke up
and I was like well I guess I better
like fix myself or like be good for my
mom while she's alive and then she died
and I was like well you know then all
these things and back to being
18 um it kind of all came to like a head
right then I still hadn't been in
therapy for physical or emotional for my
head injury um for my mom dying for my
dad getting remarried very shortly like
six months after my mom died um and then
getting kicked out and then um the abuse
that I endured during relationships with
my partners during that time too 18 it
was like well this is it um I remember
going to a party with my friends and
this is back when like four Loco was
like a really big drink it might still
be um remember I had
and I was like that's going to do it and
it didn't um I'm I don't know what
happened how if alcohol poisoning is
fixable on itself but I have never been
sicker from alcohol in my life sick for
like four days um puking throwing up and
you know still stuck in this like
depressive State um and very shortly
after that thank God whoever um a fellow
Mark is his name um he is who my
sister's dad he's who got me into yoga
and man I credit him for changing my
life for sure I'm very grateful um for
him because I really don't think I would
be here if it wasn't for like you know
these really good people that I have in
my life um Angelic humans um per se and
there's always help there but maybe I
just didn't see it growing up um but
yeah he definitely like helped pave the
way for um this piece
and yoga has been such a beneficial
everyday activity from you know just
mindfulness being aware um and believing
that I can do things that I'm not like
um have a disability um I mean I can do
things that I never thought would be
imaginable um I don't get sick like I
used to um I don't get headaches like I
used to it's you know you would think
and look at me and think I have a brain
injury and I all ACC credit that to like
a daily practice of something um and
that's amazing and yoga there's
definitely been uh some bad times that I
have found through it um but for the
most part it's been very good how old
are you now I'm 25 25 yeah and your life
is doing you're doing much better now
God I'm doing I'm doing so much better I
mean thank the Lord whoever whatever um
I still have all these like old sayings
from when I was a kid you know thank god
um but I really the last year I opened
up my own business and I got out of some
really
well I was also I was an Ault for three
years got out of that to open my own
business and there's always healing to
be done right um and interesting about
you know I was saying the four-year Mark
uh Mark timeline uh if I would have
stayed another year like who would have
knows like what have happened to me but
I I got out in the threee open up my own
space um what what kind of cult so it
wasn't a yoga cult there are of some
absolutely um it was a it was a
spiritual cult um started preo but then
when Co
started it totally
changed I don't know if that was always
the intention of the place um I started
there as an employee as a as a job I as
a yoga teacher there and they had like
you know this little mystical feel and
like small town Texas and it's like no
one has that so you know anyone who's
got any other views other than like you
know Southern Baptist Christianity oh
there's a place I can go that's not
going to reprimand me or judge me for
all these you know other beliefs that I
may have and I was like this is the
coolest place ever like wow I can't
believe this is open I get to like meet
people who um really treat me like
family
and really like believe that I'm like a
good person um CU I struggle with that
for a long time too and
so I stayed there from like like I don't
know 2019 to like I don't know maybe
like eight months later and then Co
happened obviously they shut down for a
little bit and then they opened back up
they're like hey uh you want to come
back and like teach yoga because we
don't have any teachers anymore and I
was like oh yeah because I don't have a
job I was supposed to move I was
supposed to go do all these other things
and then you know the world whatever I
was like I guess I'll do this for now
and at first I always again like very
being very intuitive my whole life
my first instinct of a person has always
been right and I don't know if this is
like some crazy you know whatever it is
I need to start really listening to it
um but the first time I went to this
place my stomach hurt and I was like oh
this is not a good vibe and the first
time I met um like a teacher there I was
like this is not good but I was told you
know through time that oh the reason why
I'm having these reactions is because
I'm just not involved enough and then if
I stay here and learn these lessons that
I will become a truly like enlightened
good person I was like oh my God okay
this sounds good uh this is what I need
and I was 19 at the time and of course
what happens when you're 19 like you
don't know the world at all nothing
nothing stays when you're 19 um and so I
really embedded myself in the
teachings and just wanting to do better
like I think that was what everyone
wants to do is like be a better person
be a better human and
looking back there's so many things that
I wish I would have stopped and said I'm
out I've got to leave um but the big
preface is they had these circles right
you would sit and you would tell your
your terrible life stories like this um
but they would use it against you so
they wanted you to be so open and
vulnerable and obviously I have like a
deep mom wound and um the abuse you know
physical emotional that I suffered from
her um it was almost replicated from one
of the teachers as like okay well now
you're my daughter and it became a very
unhealthy relationship between the two
of us um you know it was like that was
my best friend it was my boss it was my
there was no clear boundaries and it was
like constant like the phone just all
the time I was always needed there was
always something to
do and then there was this other teacher
who was definitely more int like
the I don't
know the most wild teachings for example
um we're sing the circles one day and
we're doing this like breath
work to get over something get over
trauma and it was based on like the
sacral Shakra which is sexual trauma
and
I knew I had sexual trauma uh I went to
therapy when I was 19 so this is like a
year later so I had just recently like
uncovered um
my own abuse and so I'm sharing it in
the group and I was like you know I'm
having a really hard time I'm with this
person and it keeps getting brought up
in you know our day-to-day life I don't
know how to get over it and I'm you know
seeking advice and as I'm saying this
you know heartfelt and a young woman
talking about her being raped and the
teacher is just smiling and I'm thinking
like maybe this is endearing maybe she's
like you know about to give some like
really positive
message and she s silence you know the
room there's like 30 people in this
place and she says to me why do you
think you got
raped and it was you know God like first
of all who says that and under any
circumstances doesn't matter
um and I just was dumbfound like I'm
sure it seemed like I was silent for
seven minutes I'm sure it was a few
seconds um and she goes no tell me why
do you think that happened I said
because bad [__] happens sometimes
there's not always a reason for it and
she goes well you just have to be okay
that you raped someone in a past life
and it's just karma coming back to
you and at the time I was so mad and so
just hurt and I cried and I laughed and
I was like I'm never [__] coming back
here again and of course the other
teacher who was like my mom viewed
herself as my mother was like I'm so
sorry but you know whatever makes you
feel unhappy you have to work through it
I like okay another lesson let's just
keep building lessons so it was like I
was putting myself in these traumatic
instances that didn't need to happen in
order to
heal and it wasn't just like these
circles too it was like these events
where you would go and like not sleep or
eat for like 3
days and you're supposed to have these
spiritual experiences and I'm not having
them I'm just mad and I'm like what is
going on I don't believe this something
is something is not right and again it
was like well here's another lesson that
you need to get over and get through and
that still wasn't enough for me to leave
you know spending three days out in the
freezing cold not being able not having
water not having a food source until the
last day and not being able to sleep
like what does that do that causes like
psychosis it's not healthy um no one
needs to do that to have a good life you
know
um and you know thank God I left and it
was just I think a a pivoting point
really based on um finances where I was
like I have got to do better for myself
and um I'm very thankful that that page
is over but there's still days where I
think back to some of the things that
they said to
me and the things I like even just
allowed myself to be in because Cults
are so common it just takes a
narcissistic plural or singular
individual to like lead a group like
that's all it takes even like a
narcissistic relationship that's
considered a cult um have you ever heard
of the Nexium cult have not it's
fascinating um uh Keith rieri he's like
the leader of it he's in prison but
that's like the best way I can describe
that is it's like a self-help group and
you have like these levels that you want
to achieve in yourself um and the basis
of it looks really good but then when
you start learning deeper it's like oh
that's weird but it's still not weird
enough for you to leave and it's like
they just keep kind of feeding you
little bits of peace and goodness until
it there's a Breaking Point Point
um and man just crazy and I don't know
if that was like in my path or I chose
that um I find too that a lot of people
who found their way into this place were
just like me they were struggling with
abuse they suffered from abusive mothers
and they had sexual abuse and it's like
you know tells old this time everyone's
traumatize no one has a perfect life um
there's always something that happens
and you know makes us or breaks us
and they pry on that um and it's so
upsetting to think about all the people
that maybe that's it's still happening
to um and I just know that my mom was
like still around she be like what did
you get yourself into like that's nuts I
didn't teach you any of that um but my
mom going back to that God bless her I
feel so sad that she was so sick for so
long um and even just like a
manifestation if that was the illness
from her mind going into the body um cuz
I said she had a paralyzed stomach it
looked like she was 9 months pregnant
and she had lost I think four children
um through miscarriages three or four
and so just being stuck in the state of
like having this really swollen belly
but like skinny otherwise um and that's
what you see every day in the mirror
and and I don't know if that made her
switch every time she would look at the
mirror um because it wasn't just a
everyday it was like a once in a blue
moon um eyes would darken and then it
was a completely different person and
she had like two different identities um
one was definitely like a a small
toddler or or like a baby and she would
always try to run away and again we
lived out in the middle of nowhere and
she
definitely had other relationships other
than my father during um their marriage
and every time she would try to run away
she would try to go to this other guy
that she was seeing um and it would call
out his name and I just thought he was a
friend at the time I didn't know any
better um so he would have to come calm
her down um I mean would run out she
would be gone sometimes for hours come
back with like scraped knees tattered
clothes and would have no idea because
we had you know acres and Acres of of
land so who knows how far out she would
go um and that was just like a very
scared version of her and then that
wasn't bad because that never really
affected me it was the I'm going to kill
you version of herself um and just
rooted maybe in hatred for her abusers
um that she would unleash it um I was
I've always been a very I don't know
talkative kid back talking I guess and I
would always R my mouth and one day I
guess she just had enough and so she's
like pick your Pick Your Weapon to be
hit with and it was either like belt or
spoon and I remember picking up a
plastic like Ladle because i' had never
been hit with that yet and it was like
the last util like utensil I maybe this
won't hurt as
bad and I thought it'd be like a one one
spank but again eyes turned and it
turned into like a full body from like
shoulders to feet and I was covered in
welts for like days couldn't go to
school my mom she wouldn't know what she
did until she saw the effect afterwards
um
I mean just just getting beat black and
blue um and she changes she like shifts
she drops the spoon and she just looks
at me and she's like you can't go to
school and that's the only thing she
said and so I stayed at home for days
and I love staying at home because I was
like oh I get to take care of Mom I get
to be with my favorite person because
that's all you know as a kid is your
parents and as like [__] up as they
are you want them to love you and you
want them to like be so proud of you
everyone faces that it's like okay I'm
going to be the best caretaker of my mom
today that I
can
and just so many other you know abusive
Rampages she would go in like back to
that Chapel I was talking
about I was always so scared of
tornadoes as a kid that's why I say my
childhood was like a tornado um of
course Texas what happens tornadoes and
I think my dad was on a trip somewhere
with his family with his friends and my
mom I was probably four or five I don't
know if I was in school yet maybe I was
and she's like there's a tornado um we
have to prepare for it and I was like
okay so we all go into the chapel which
is me I don't remember my sister being
there but she had to have been maybe if
she was in school um and then our pets
and mind you my mom was a hoarder of all
things so animals we had like 35 dogs at
one time inside and outside crazy and
not cool so we're all like piled in this
place and we like take we go to sleep
and it feels like I was in there
for several several days it could have
been a few hours because it's a child
time no one knows there was no clock in
there um but we're eating like the
prepared meals we're like winding up our
flashlights we're peeing in a bucket and
take a little nap I wake up she's like
the house is gone we have to stay in
here until your dad gets
home and I'm so so terrified you know
little me I'm like praying on my knees
like at the chapel and I'm like God if
you just save me and save this house
like you know I always gave ultimatums I
was like I'll stop sucking my thumb like
I thought that was so bad of me to do as
a kid
and I've always like shook when I was
scared and that's still a thing I do
like if I'm really nervous like I will
definitely like visually shake and I
that's like the first memory I have of
that is just sitting there just shaking
in the Pew eating this like I don't know
Chef boy Rd canned soup
and then my mom I don't know what she's
doing if she's taking a nap or doing
something else I open the door and the
house is still [__]
there and of course it is cuz no tornado
would have come in I would have heard it
as a child you don't know and you
believe your parents and everything they
say and nothing was ever said about that
again I never told my dad I never told
anybody and it wasn't until recently
that I've I've been writing a book too
about my life cuz there's so many
stories um that I've been like really
uncovering
all these old memories and it's
fascinating how we keep them and we hide
them in our brains until we're ready for
them to come out like in therapy I was
19 I had been in therapy for a long time
as a
kid but um I hadn't uncovered that I had
been actually assaulted when I was I was
17 so right in that middle of those four
years um as a teenager and my therapist
just looks at me because I'm
shaking and she's like what's going on
like you're talking about something
that's not related to like this feeling
that you're having like have you been
assaulted and it was just like Pandora's
Box
opened and it wasn't just even that
memory that came back it was like all
these other things from my childhood
that weren't sexually abusive but
abusive in other senses
and thank God I had started doing yoga
then right because I don't think I could
have handled um you know the next phase
of my life to come if it weren't for
that but I was so ready to to heal and
so ready to like get over my own
nonsense cuz obviously like people have
done terrible things to me but I've also
not been a great person for a lot of my
life people think that they're perfect
or you know it's like well me victim
it's like no like I've definitely made
my own choices no one told me to go to
the cult no one said it was a cult I
chose to go um no one forced me into
these relationships that I you know got
myself into and they were always a
choice but I think it was a choice based
out of I wanted my mom to love me so bad
so I chose men that were very similar to
her in Rage and in abuse and just the
flip-flop of emotions because that was
what I had based love off of um and I
see that a lot it's so common and you
think you look at it and it's like yeah
don't do that but when you're in it I
don't know like no nothing anyone can
tell you makes it better or makes it go
away and you think that they're the
problem because they're telling you that
you're in a bad relation reltionship and
you're like well I'm going to marry this
person and I did I was
engaged 3 years ago something like that
um when I was in the cult and I
definitely was just like not living
truthfully to myself
and I didn't even say yes when he
proposed I just said okay I said sure I
think um I knew we weren't actually
going to get married because I would not
have done that um but if someone doesn't
like your partner it's like well I chose
this person so I'm going to make sure
that we like you know stay put um we
weren't together for we were like two
years
um and it was so hard like I left the
cult and I left him within like a
month's time together and I don't know
if something uncovered in me that was
like you have got to just do better
you've been wanting to do better your
whole life and this is your chance and I
did um and now I'm actually with a
really good person um really similar
beliefs and um calm and not this back
and forth High highs low lows um it's
just very it's always stable what has
helped you
[Music]
stabilize not taking advice from people
that I don't want to be
like and obviously the yoga and I think
I don't know age that could be a part of
it like you have to grow grow through
things to go through them um I've always
been an old soul I've always been told
that from you know little bitty and it's
like thanks that's because I've been
traumatized my whole life that's why um
and I've always hung out with older
people I think it's just like not caring
what other people think about me has
been like a really um big release cuz
you know in the cult and in my childhood
it was like well everyone has to think
I'm perfect right like it's me hi um and
then now I was like well if I make a
mistake that's great because now I can
learn from the mistakes and I embrace my
mistakes now it's like look at what I
did how silly is that and not taking
things too seriously um because
everything always works
out everything always works out and it
might not seem like that in the moment
and there's like this little parachute
that I now keep with me it's like if it
feels like I'm falling it's like well
it's going to work out and it's going to
catch me and if it doesn't work out then
I I guess I'll die and then you know I
lived a great life um so far but it's
crazy cuz you don't remember how painful
things are like you can remember like
that was terrible but like your body
can't bring up the pain physically like
if you cut yourself you know it hurts
but you can't remember that um and it's
like that you know from childhood until
I would say 19 20 um my life was just
like a raincloud it was so sad and I was
so depressed and had no purpose
for happiness I thought that the world
was inherently bad and people were
inherently bad and then you know these
last 5 years of my life there's still
been some bad but it's like this it's
crazy I think that I've had a good life
even though this whole time before that
um I think it's more just the energy you
put out into the world um I'm really
trying to make a difference and help
others and Empower them too because it
feels so disempowering um when you come
from trauma and you come from [__] and
you don't feel like there's anyone that
can actually understand understand you
or hear you um and it's like well that's
okay do the yoga you'll probably feel
better and if you don't that's okay too
there's so many other ways to heal
yourself and um make yourself feel like
a better
person and I'm fascinated with people's
stories and obviously you are too with
hearing people um and just like the root
cause of life and like [__] is just
parents like they parents and then their
parents and it just keeps going on
um and like we were talking ear like I
don't want children I don't have a
desire to have kids
um and I've never wanted kids either
from like a time as a child like that
will break the cycle it will break the
cycle it will and I'll just love my pets
endlessly um give them all all the
goodness um but I do teach in schools
and stuff teach yoga to kids and maybe
that's like the cycle to breaking um but
just not having my own that has never
sound sounded like a good time um they
always say you'll change your mind
you're only 25 I like well I've never
had the thought to do it and if I do I
just don't think I will but never say
never right that's what they always say
and that's what I've always said like I
never thought I'd be an Ault Never Say
Never yeah you think the chaotic
childhood you had kind of LED you to
make those kind of decisions oh 100% I
think
that I've always I feel like I've had a
good innate sense of like right and
wrong I'm a Libra like you know
balancing scales
uh and I don't know yes no maybe so it's
hard too to think like the
trauma has rooted itself in such
different ways than like my brain injury
has uh so it's like I don't know where
my memory problems stem from if it is
from the brain injury or if it is from
the years of trauma um and so it's like
well since my brain is maybe not wired
correctly is that would led me there or
is it the past and I think maybe it's
just both it's like a collection of
everything nothing's just I I say this
it's nothing's black and white but I do
live a very black and white life I have
a very hard time being in the gray area
I TR I want to but I find that when I'm
too far in the gray uh that's when I got
myself in trouble so I got to like have
my own uh sense of yes trust my gut and
just stick with that
um yeah I that's a good question to
think about like what led me there where
What's led me anywhere was it all choice
or was it like some predetermined idea
in the world I don't
know because when things are good
they're great and when things are bad
they're they're really bad too um but
I've been in this really good calm sense
or Baseline since um for how
long you know honestly my partner um now
ever since we
met I mean he holds me to a high
standard too and like we are very good
at um telling each other if something is
is not right you know there's no um gray
it's like well let's um let's fix this
issue that we're having and I think he
holds me to such a high standard of Love
Like unconditionally that I've not
experienced before um last December so
almost well year ago I guess I had went
through a really really hard time it was
only for like 3 weeks but it felt you
know I had been in this really high
bubble you know opening up my own studio
and living a good life and then it just
kind of came crashing down it's honestly
writing my book has been bringing up a
lot of stuff and I was really trying to
focus on that and I think I went too far
on it I was just sitting there writing
writing writing and I didn't take breaks
um and I didn't want to leave the house
for like three weeks and I was
struggling I was sick and didn't bet an
ey totally there for me and it's so hard
for me to get like the fear of being
sick uh cuz my mom again sick she never
had a good day it was always something's
wrong and I don't know if that was real
or fake um but even coming here the
paranoia about getting covid or getting
sick or um if I have a big trip coming
up it's like oh God please don't let me
get sick like or I will try you know
wash my hands and and not living in
complete paranoia all the time but it's
such a rooted thing that my plans are
going to get messed up because someone's
sick cuz as a kid you know my basketball
games they would happen and my mom would
say I'll be there and then what happens
oh I was sick so I
can't and it's interesting my partner
too he's got such good parents like a
really good family and they're amazing
and they like love me too and they don't
ever have these problems or these
thoughts and if he gets sick it's like
oh everyone goes to take care of no one
resents him for being sick and I feel
like I was always res resented for being
sick as a kid um even those years you
know that I was bedridden um from my my
brain
injury it's like I wasn't even allowed
to like fully enjoy that time to heal
because I can't be sick um and my dad
definitely has taken on a lot of that I
can't imagine being married to my mom
like the abuse he went through too you
know I watched him try to be killed by
my mom twice
um and so he has definitely taken on a
more masculine approach to the healing
um of just you know brush it off
and recently like I've had some heart
issues um and I was telling him you know
like I think I need to go to the doctor
for this he's like oh you're fine and
it's always you're fine and maybe I am
maybe I'm not um but he's so I think
he's so scared about getting sick too or
someone being sick or me having any kind
of Gene connection to my mom um cuz I
did this blood test recently too about
this G mutation that I have and I have
it and I told him and he was like well I
can't have that I was like you probably
do because it comes from both parents um
so I don't think he's able to to view
that and that's okay maybe that's just
not his journey um I have definitely
learned a lot from him we were not
cool until like probably again since me
and my current partner have been
together um I didn't talk to him I
refused to see him I really just did not
like him or agree
with Excuse me any of the choices um he
was making which who cares right like
he's he's a grown adult um but recently
we've I've actually like not dreaded
going to see him so that's that piece of
the world is healing too um so I'm just
very curious like where my life is in a
few years if I'm still in this really
good place or if it goes back we'll
check in with you in a few years right
yeah all right Gabrielle thank you so so
much for sharing your story thank you
thank you I wish you lots of luck from
here appreciate it thank you very
[Music]
much